and here it is folks this is it this is
the video game movie in which the future
of all video game movies may be hinging
on if this sucks then why bother why do
we even bother let's talk about it
Warcraft 2 Warcraft is directed by
Duncan Jones it's based on the mythology
early mythology of the Warcraft lore and
in Warcraft the orcs are on their world
the world the pot it's dying
there's nothing there for them so the
super sorcerer orc is pretty much the
shang tsung of orcs known as golden
opens up this portal to Azeroth the orcs
come through so now the humans have to
stop that from happening before more
orcs come through but an orc chieftain
named der Tann starts thinkin maybe
working with the humans is the best way
for all of us to survive because there
is a bigger evil that needs to be
stopped you got your vague summation of
this mixed bag so let's talk about it
this movie is a mixed bag let's be
honest with ourselves we didn't want it
to be we wanted this to be the greatest
video game movie that has ever existed
but sadly it is a mixed bag and among
this mixed bag let's talk about what I
liked first of all the visual effects
whoa this movie looks nice that first
shot of Durotan is just on his face and
I'm like that looks real looks more real
than any picture I can put here to
illustrate that for it it's clear that
there's a lot of CGI in this movie but
it does look good and the fighting
discouraged and the humans they were
bone-crushing League rate or grub up
their hammer and they smash a human
being you just feel the humans bones and
armor just crushing under his hammer it
was awesome dude and that's what I
wanted in a fight between the orcs and
humans I wanted it to feel that gritty
dirt and is hands-down the best
character in the entire movie he is who
carries this movie I liked Johnny main
human well enough but let's face it
Durotan and golden I thought was great -
he's like Shang soon meets the Emperor
from Star Wars - he's a dick he's a
douchebag and he played the role very
well and the magic was great - yeah this
world has magic this movie has magic in
it and in a movie with magic in a world
with magic I want this movie to
illustrate magic how I see magic there's
a reason I always pick a mage in stories
like this because magic is the
superpower man it's a force to be
reckoned with and sometimes in movies
with magic you don't really feel that
way you're like yeah well magics nice
but look your religions and ancient
weapons are no match for a good blaster
at your side
nor in this case a sword but the magic
in this movie the way the visuals mixed
with the sound mixed with the basis you
really felt the magic are you saying
mages were cool however let's talk about
the biggest glaring issue in this movie
that's the pacing oh my god the pace
this movie is clearly pulling from rich
lore the likes of which has lore stacked
on lore stacked on mythology point is
yeah it's deep and they need to
condense it into about a two hour movie
about halfway through this movie I was
like this is what would happen if they
took Game of Thrones season 1 and crush
it into a 2 hour movie which is probably
why they opted to make it a series with
10 episodes a season because you can
just tell the story better the whole
time I was watching this movie I was
like this would have made a better
series granted you couldn't do all the
visual effects they were doing in this
movie if you made it a series so it's
kind of a no-win situation for Warcraft
that are making a trilogy to tell this
one story point is this movie had a lot
going on in it and generally speaking
the transitions were not smooth at all
it's jumping all over these cities and
if you're a fan of the Lord you know
where the cities are that's great and
that's gonna last for about 20 minutes
and then after that you're gonna be like
okay while the jumping around at a point
the generic mage kid goes to this super
mage council and you're just left like
who are they they mentioned them a
couple times in the movie but if you
blink you miss it and they didn't
mention them or illustrate them enough
to be relevant enough to just plop them
at your doorstep you're like hey here
are these people now and among the
pacing in this movie there is a romance
that you're not buying at all you're
like why does there have to be a romance
and that's just an example these are a
couple of examples illustrating what I'm
trying to say about the pacing the
pacing bogged this movie down to such a
degree there is entertainment in this
movie for sure especially if you're a
Warcraft friend you have yourself some
fanservice and there is a great movie in
here but it's kind of like my lawn I am
shitty at taking care of my lawn I get
homeowners association letters all the
time and one can argue this
movie has greatness in it like I can
argue to the homeowners association that
my lawn has greatness in it if you just
look past all the weeds guys in the end
the Warcraft movie has some great
fanservice it has some really cool
it has a couple of good characters
surprisingly good characters Durotan is
a straight-up badass I just wanted
Warcraft to be this good and it was only
so good
painfully enough this is not the
Warcraft movie we deserved or needed as
it stands right now
Warcraft would have been a better time
if I were drunk ya know it's a party
jugo the director's cut of this movie
maybe that would make it better I feel
like there might be a director's cut to
this movie and I'm looking forward to
that and I'll tell you why when watching
this movie the way it's presented it
feels like there are scenes just missing
I don't mean missing like oh they just
didn't write that scene missing like I
feel like the scene probably existed or
this scene might have been longer it was
just edited down to make the movie two
hours long so it would fit in a
conventional timeframe for a cinematic
movie scenes that could fill in the gaps
things that could better inform the
audience scenes that can get the
audience more attached to the characters
scenes that can draw out the tragedy
there are a couple of scenes where
tragedy strikes you don't really feel it
you don't really give a you don't
really care I feel like in terms of the
movie I saw that is Warcraft that's a
two-hour long movie I feel like a proper
one probably should be about three hours
long so if this movie was supposed to be
three hours long bring on the director's
cut here's hope and fingers crossed
alright guys so Warcraft have you seen
it what did you think about it again I
feel like if you're a big Warcraft fan
you're gonna enjoy this movie a lot more
than some other people might so if you
enjoyed hey rock on you do you but
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more